[Music]
the deck of a railway bridge is
typically built of wood Timbers called
bridge ties they're bolted to steel
support beams located on concrete piers
over the water or gully below the rails
on which the train travels are bolted to
the wooden ties what absorbs the noise
and vibration of the passing train the
load the railway bridge will carry
determines the size of its ties to
calculate the load engineers factor in
the number of tracks volume of traffic
weight of the transported cargo and
whether the bridge is straight or curved
a curve will put additional stress on
the structure the wood of choice is oak
because it's hard and strong when the
logs arrive at the sawmill they come
face to face with a menacing looking
device called a de Barker
a conveyor moves the shipment toward the
debarker then drops a single log in
front of it on two spending rollers the
rollers rotate the log while the
debarker makes its way from one end to
the other it shoes off the bark with its
sharp tooth blades
[Music]
what the debarker shaves off is put to
good use
the bar gets processed into gardening
mulch and they burn the sawdust in the
wood-fired boiler that runs another part
of the plant next one log at a time
drops into a mobile carriage that runs
it through a circular saw the carriage
has sensors which detect the logs
extremities and report its dimensions to
a console located in the operators cab
the operator interprets the data using a
joystick controller he flips the log
into whichever position maximizes the
yield the first few runs trim off the
rough surface and square the shape the
next runs cut boards which the sawmill
sells to flooring plants this continues
until the log is the exact dimensions of
the bridge tie again nothing is wasted
the sawmill processes the cut-offs into
wood chips which it then sells to
companies that make particle board
strand board and similar construction
materials
[Music]
the Seoul mill stacks the ties for
transfer to the bridge mill next door
the role of the bridge mill is to frame
the bridge also known as dapping that's
the process of making the specific holes
and notches in each tie for attaching it
to the steel beam on which it will sit
at the bridge mill the bridge layout
supervisor processes one tie at a time
he carefully reviews the engineers
blueprints which assign a number to each
and every time these numbers specify
precisely where the saw has to cut
notches and where the drill has to bore
holes the locations of these notches and
holes vary depending on the ties
position on the bridge so he must follow
the blueprints meticulously
[Music]
after measuring and marking it all out
he sends the tie to the DAP saw the
operator sets up each cut lining up the
mark with laser lights which indicate
the location and the cutting depth of
the blade
[Music]
the notches are just the right size to
fit over the steel beam on which the tie
will lie next a worker using a drill
press bores holes for hook bolts which
go through the tie to secure it onto the
steel beams each tie receives a metal
identification tag which includes the
bridge and tie numbers on each end
workers nail on a mesh plate made of
rust-proof galvanized steel the plate
has teeth designed to grasp and hold
together the wood fiber to prevent the
end from splitting after nailing the ID
tag to one of the end plates workers
force in both plates with the press
the ties last stop is the adjacent
treatment plant they spend 24 hours
inside a high-temperature high-pressure
chamber which penetrates them with the
creosote borate solution this protects
the wood from rod and insect damage and
extends the ties lifespan from about a
decade to at least 25 years
[Music]